now the next one is a little bit weird
and so accordingly I've given a bit of a
weird name I call this property not the
an Traverse or dummy or symmetry
properties but I call it the round off
property now I don't know how many of
you know what a round off is so does
anybody yeah this is done gymnastics of
any form before and see what a round off
is they won't know okay well I'm gonna
say to you is very simple I can't do one
for you um once upon a time I could do
one but um I'll explain them in the
closet then then you're safe you guys
know what to cut wheelies yeah you don't
wanna copy this so you're sort of riding
along you gaining speed
you kind of turn sideways and your body
goes that way around okay and then you
use sort of land on the other side okay
a roundup is different in that you're
sort of running in a certain direction
once you launch into your car wheel you
do a twist in the middle of the air like
spinning around in this direction so
when you land right when you land you're
actually facing in the opposite
direction from where you came from
that's really cool so gymnasts tend to
do this so they can launch into
backflips right so it's like okay I'm
running I've got to change this kind of
momentum like straight forward
diminutive into something that I can
turn backwards and upwards and backwards
so round off is where you start in one
direction and by the end of it you've
turned around like Midway you've turned
around so do you like this and let me
see if we can um draw a diagram and
understand what it means for interval
here it is so the integral again it's
very similar
it starts off very similar to this
symmetry property but it can work with
any function okay
okay I love this property no how do we
illustrate this what's going on okay so
I'm thinking about again a function any
function not just part of everyone's
from negative a to X so considering
these boundaries right now what is this
food what are the thinking about is
first let's have a look at this guy
right so that's like the first half or
sorry I should say the second half of
you - yeah from naught to a so run a
negative a to a of sort of slice it down
the middle and taking the right-hand
side okay and then you add on to it this
is what's that about okay we absolutely
need a picture and then we will do a
rigorous proof now I'm going to choose a
function you can choose like until you
could use any function you I but this
will make it a little easier to see I'm
going to choose a function that is not
symmetrical because you get more special
properties on actual symmetrical
functions here okay so if I do say let's
take us exponential function any
exponential function you like okay so it
could be e to the X e to the X 3x
whatever if I want to take the battery
from negative a to a right what kind of
shape am I getting well something like
something like this now my boundaries
and I got the same distance on either
side so this is the kind of shape so
what am I saying over there on the right
hand side well remember you got the
first bit which is the same function
yeah it's the same exponential function
but I've only taken half of the area
I will not hop in terms of counting but
half in terms of beautiful so there's 0
to n that makes it so there's one huh
now what is this other part signifies
this sum F of negative x DX and now I
wonder if you're starting to see why
I've called it this ok what's the
relationship between these two functions
there's a horizontal flip right or
Harlin's but so you've got the same
function
I'm gonna turn it from this way is that
exponential function
now I'm integrating it because it's in
the same I've nestled it to the same
integral right I'm entering it over the
same interval here right again from
naught to a do you see that okay now
just by virtue of the shape you can see
oh right what this signifies right is
I'm taking the positive boundaries but
I'm turning the integrand backwards
right so I've gone this way and then
halfway I've reversed direction does
that make sense like this integral here
actually represents this component yes
so now I hope you can see why I've
called it the router property because
literally you're taking one part in the
normal direction and in half way you're
going in the opposite direction okay now
there's the picture but how do we prove
it now in the past I'm proving this and
people tend to look and they say well
were you trying to prove an identity of
some claim like this you usually go from
messy are to strip more straightforward
right so you start from the right you go
to the left in this case because that's
got more stuff on it just because a
break don't have a point you can look up
a video I I'm gonna go from left this
time as if most of these ones we kind of
did here right I'm gonna show you how to
prove this property and we're gonna do
it completely rigorously algebraically
okay so let's begin
he's approved and we're gonna start with
the left hand side I want to end up over
here
okay now I'm actually going to take
advantage robbery that I haven't written
on the board yeah but that's because I'm
going to refer to a lot in period two
which is that see this here how I've
like talked about slicing on this
interval okay this goes from negative a
to pay that's one long interval I can
break this up into however many chunks I
want okay now I'm given I can give this
a name later on but for now just
continue self in fact that if I want to
because this is an area I can think of
it as a composite area if I like okay so
the way I'm going to divide this up sort
of accords with the boundaries that I
have here you notice that so this has a
not to a part in it so I want a nor to a
part of some kind that comes out of this
okay so if I'm going to do that there
will be a not a part but that leaves
behind a negative a to not part and I'd
like to do it in order from left to
right that whale get not get confuse so
I'm gonna go from negative a to zero
yep and then I'm gonna go from 0 to a so
again I'm gonna focus on this later on
in period two because we'll use this
property as simple as it is so so so
useful now again just like just like
normal you think mmm I'm trying to prove
something
how close is this to my destination and
it's actually quite close right it's
about once about halfway there which
part do I have in which pie is missing
yeah okay so this plot looks good that's
exactly what I want right but this part
here is missing and instead I've got
this guy okay so the question is how do
I turn this into this there's a variety
of ways
okay but the easiest way will be to use
a substitution okay
I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna take advantage
of what you say okay I'm going to bring
in a substitution so maybe you wanna put
this over here in the end on the right
hand side what can I introduce what
could make this work yeah
okay so III need a negative appearing
inside that fi of whatever and I don't
have it
okay so therefore I'm going to introduce
it I've got an exit the move it but I
want there to be something inside so I'm
going to call that negative you gonna
call it negative you now this is
publishes two things for me it's great
the first thing in it accomplishes is
that it's going to put a negative sign
inside there now the variable would
change but I know if i play my cards
right it doesn't matter what variable
I've got in there I can chop and change
out however I please as long as
everything else is good that's the first
thing it changes the second thing it
should change as I'm going to show in a
minute
is that when you make a substitution for
a definite integral you have to change
three things do you not become change
the integrate the full queue integrating
what are the other two things
interchange you've got to change the
boundaries right where you're
integrating from which is actually one
of my problems either is that I actually
don't want negative a to zero of what
zero to a okay and that's going to
happen when I did it if if this is the
substitution I'm making let's take the
original boundaries as see what happens
right it x equals negative a what does
that imply about you it's just going to
be a negative of a feedback what about x
equals zero which is the upper boundary
well yeah zero is its own opposite so
I've changed my boundaries
one more thing I've changed yeah the
variable of integration so I'm going to
integrate X with respect to u which in
this case just gives me good okay
which of course I can write with the
negative on this side if I like okay
because that's the substitution about it
this is fantastic because in one fell
swoop this awkward integral turns into
exactly what I want almost so let's
write this as I mentioned in the past
even though it's not necessary I'm going
to write the variable that the
boundaries are changing as well because
that helps me remember that I I've
changed this so my lower battery used to
be negative a but now it ends
my upper boundary stills either okay
what am i replacing inside here this is
going to be X is negative u that's F of
negative u so far so good
okay now I just need to change the
variable integration so I've got a DX
that was already there and then I kind
of substitute this in for one okay so I
probably want to flip this upside down
too that'll be useful so I can cancel my
DX is thankfully the reciprocal of one
still Y so that's nice okay so in here
I'm gonna write minus sorry negative do
DX yep happy with that cancel cancel and
then I stopped all that definitely to go
pending off on the side cool almost
there right now what do you notice this
happen I actually let's see if I can
squeeze in two lines and went with the
amount in one my boundaries are going
from a to not and that's completely
deliberate hey it looks like it's weird
but it's what I want
what am I got in here well I've got that
F of negative something that I was after
then you've got the D you here and
there's a negative sign to constant
someone checked out the front but do you
see which property this is invoking now
which one which one do I want
we have the very first one the reverse
property right because I had my
boundaries in the wrong order and I'm
gonna use that then you sign at the
front to change them to be what I want
okay plus not only am I going to do that
not only am I going to take advantage of
this reverse property but it's all in
terms of use at the moment that doesn't
matter right these are gonna these use
again a bit replaced by some numbers in
a minute I am at zero okay so if what I
can label it however I please so I'm
going to do these on these two steps
both at once I'm gonna use the reverse
property which turned this into a
positive thrown or 2a and then second
I'm going to change all of my use all in
Texas because it's just a dummy variable
negative x okay now I only tried to
squeeze into lines and I'm working there
because the last line the last line is
this line is it not I've got two
integrals over the saves sorry yeah two
integrals over the same interval not ank
so I can combine them like this you see
how I did that so it's really important
that you do all of this like like I said
before it's like wow so much algebra so
I'm trying to add words to all of this
but if you can add pictures as well it's
like oh yeah I know what this is about
this is that change of order and here
the algebra that rigorously proves it